-New York, New York, New York.
All right, calm down. Calm down.
I got to catch the 2 train
in a minute.
I'm 26.
Yeah, I'm an adult now.
I don't like it.
[ Laughter ]
I was tricked.
My mom told me,
"When you get grown,
you can do
whatever you want to do."
That's not true.
[ Laughter ]
When you're grown, you can do
whatever you can afford to do.
That's different.
[ Laughter ]
Paying bills.
I miss free fun.
I miss playing tag
because I was never it.
[ Laughter ]
All my friends knew if I was it,
that was it.
That's the end of the game.
[ Laughter and applause ]
I'm not chasing you
around no neighborhood.
The living room, maybe.
Not the neighborhood.
I'm not chasing you
around the neighborhood.
I hated freeze tag.
It's got to be
the dumbest game ever.
They only play it
on the hottest day.
Tag, you can't move.
Like, wait, wait.
You couldn't have froze me
in the shade over there?
[ Laughter ]
I'm-a thaw out over here.
I don't know if you know.
[ Laughter ]
I hung out with everybody.
I don't care about your race.
I don't care, you know.
White, black, I don't care.
My favorite friend was white,
named Tanner.
Yeah.
[ Laughter ]
Tanner had
the best post-play snacks.
[ Laughter ]
One time we was playing
at his house,
he pulled out some Lunchables.
And it messed me up
because I didn't even know
you could eat Lunchables
at home.
[ Laughter and applause ]
I thought you had to be
in school to eat Lunchables.
[ Applause ]
I was so excited.
I ate two semesters worth of
Lunchables at his house.
[ Laughter ]
Yeah. It was a new experience.
That's what life's about.
New experiences.
That's where, I think,
racism comes from --
lack of experiences or doing
stuff with other people.
Do your favorite thing
with other races.
I was blessed to do that
as a kid growing up.
Like, my favorite thing to do
growing up was sleepovers.
Remember sleepovers?
Yeah, go over somebody else's
house,
mess their stuff up,
then go home.
[ Laughter ]
I remember the first time
I slept over Tanner's house.
It was amazing.
I learned so much about --
I didn't know you can make
so much noise
at white people's house
and their parents don't get mad.
[ Laughter and applause ]
It's 3:00 in the morning.
All you hear is Tanner's dad go,
"Tanner, what in tarnations?"
I was like, "Hold on.
What's tarnations?"
[ Laughter ]
Tanner was like,
"I'm sorry, Father.
We're just playing
a game of tag."
His dad got mad.
He was like, "Without me?"
[ Applause ]
He said, "Okay, I got something
for you busters 'cause I'm it.
One, two."
And I just froze.
Yeah, I never heard
no black parent count up.
[ Laughter and applause ]
Unh-unh.
But they will count down
on you fast.
[ Laughter ]
And my mama was so gangster,
she would count and name a chore
that better magically be done
in between each number.
She'd just start out threatening
everybody like,
"Y'all got five seconds
to be in that bed.
And I'm talking about
in the bed,
not on your way to the bed,
not by the bed.
I'm talking about I want
knees in sheets.
Five.
And your clothes better be
ironed for school
in the morning too.
[ Laughter ]
Four.
And your teeth better be
brushed.
Three.
And there better be some gas
in my car
'cause if there ain't no gas
in my car --"
[ Laughter and applause ]
Like, I'm in kindergarten. That
ain't got nothing to do with me.
[ Applause ]
Learn, people, man.
You got to learn about
being with them.
Like I know,
as a young black kid,
I grew up thinking
white kids didn't get whoopings.
And that's not true.
[ Laughter ]
It's not white kids
don't get physical whoopings,
but it be mental.
[ Laughter ]
White parents
say stuff to their kids
that they need counseling
before they hit 33.
[ Laughter and applause ]
But you wouldn't know that
if you're not there.
I'm at Tanner's house.
I don't know
what he did at school,
but his daddy would snap.
He was like, "You know what?
This is some real malarkey,
pal."
I said, "Oh."
He said, "Jesus H. Christ."
I say, "Hold on, Jesus got
a middle name? I didn't --"
[ Laughter ]
That's when I knew it was over.
He was like,
"You know what, Tanner?
I'm so -- I'm so mad at you.
Your grandfather's probably
turning over in his grave
right now."
I said, "Damn."
[ Laughter ]
What can you actually do
for somebody to turn over
in their grave?
[ Laughter ]
Like, can you imagine that?
Oh, he just failed Spanish
again.
[ Laughter and applause ]
Como se dice?
It made me think, because my
grandaddy got a messed-up hip.
So somebody got to go down there
and help him turn over.
[ Laughter ]
I'm Leonard Ouzts.
Thank y'all so much.
I appreciate you.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Thank you. Thank you.
Leonard Ouzts!
See him Thursday nights
starring in "Abby's" on NBC.
Very funny show.